moreau [ __ ]
montr conformément aux bons sentiments
c'est pas du rock satanique c'est du
black métal le hellfest et m'ont appelé
ils nous veulent comme attendu tout
comme en ont bien eu un désistement mais
on s'en branle
on n'est pas prêt pour un truc aussi
gros les 18 heures la mère de la
baby-sitter
je sens que se tourne c'est un cauchemar
donc on va se faire une petite halte
d'échauffement histoire de retrouver un
peu de cohésion est aussi sans mal
physique les bords de picasso fric oui
c'est ça comme des vampires alors qu'il
est même si l'on roulait à 60 les
vampires pourrait se trouver au portugal
c'est pas faux on trouve une solution
pour se barrer ici j'aurais pu
s'attacher quatre pavillons noirs genre
au coeur on a braqué une veine des
scoubidous je crois savoir us ou as400
borgne est le plus grand festival heavy
metal de france national beaux jours
vous aller au festival a été suivez nous
au boulot mais c'est la fête à la presse
pourquoi on est vraiment en enfer en
fait